the unesco world heritage list is
comprised of outstanding natural and
cultural sites
for almost 200 countries they are
recognized as the heritage of all
humankind
since 1990 seven ukrainian sites places
of worship
residences and old growth forests belong
to the world heritage list
besides another three elements have been
added to the representative list
of the intangible cultural heritage of
humanity ukraine is among the countries
on the unesco world heritage list
this means ukrainian architecture songs
ceramics
and old growth forests outstanding
cultural natural riches
belong to all generations of humankind
here are 10 ukrainian sites and
traditions under unesco's protection
these ten listed items
showcase ukraine's cultural wealth item
number one
the historic city center of libya and
saint europe cathedral
europe's architectural and cultural
traditions have left a noticeable mark
on your view
and yet the city also retains authentic
ukrainian traditions
evil was founded during the late middle
ages and became a thriving political and
commercial hub
thanks to its favorable location the
oldest part of the city consists of the
castle hill
with the remains of the castle itself
and the surrounding network of streets
and squares
that formed from the 13th to the 17th
century the view city center is a
harmonious combination
of places of worship public buildings
and dwellings
in the renaissance and baroque styles
unesco recognized the view as a world
heritage site
as the city is a remarkable example of
urban planning
where the architectural and cultural
traditions of eastern europe
are interwoven with those of italy and
germany the city is home to a range of
ethnic groups
which form separate yet interdependent
communities
a little further from the city center on
top of a hill is the baroque
architectural ensemble
of saint judah cathedral built in the
18th century
the cathedral combines the features of
the eastern and western
european architectural and artistic
traditions
it was once the center of the ukrainian
greek catholic church
item number two peter kievka painting
petra kievka decorative painting is a
type of folk painting that originated
from the village petrichuvka
and pudniprovia the people of petra
kievka decorate their walls
crockery and other household objects
with imaginative floral designs
inspired by the local nature flowers and
birds are the most widespread ornaments
while birds animals and humans are quite
rare
in the 1930s petr kievka crafts women
established a workshop in cave
they began painting porcelain on an
industrial scale
applying the color to non-traditional
black background
a specialized art school was opened in
petticovica
today the village is home to the
petrikievka folk art center
where visitors come to learn and engage
with the artists who carry on the
tradition
in 2013 petr kievka painting was added
to the list of intangible cultural
heritage
of humanity item number three the kozak
songs of zapposia and pudniprovia
the traditional songs that were sung by
the zappos
are on the list of intangible cultural
heritage of humanity
they require immediate protection the
drawn-out melodies are mainly performed
by groups
mostly without musical accompaniment
occasionally with a bandura
a traditional ukrainian plucked string
instrument
these songs were traditionally performed
by men these days they are more often
sung by women
they tell of the kozak campaigns and
battles the lives of kazakh
chieftains and relationships between
kozaks and women
however not all songs about kozaks are
considered as traditional kazakh works
but kozak songs are mostly performed by
the amateur folk ensembles
of putniprovia as well as individual
performers and informal groups
who gather from time to time on major
holidays
most of the performers are over 70 years
old and have been singing this way
for most of their lives preserving this
link with the past
the tradition is passed down from
generation to generation
however due to breaks in this continuity
and the decreasing numbers of performers
the songs need to be recorded and
preserved for future generations
item number four the wooden churches of
the carpathian region in ukraine and
poland
sixteen vagible wooden churches half of
which are in ukraine
the other half from poland are
recognized as part of unesco world
heritage
these are the best preserved wooden
churches in the carpathian region
built in the traditional style with
horizontal logs
since they have been repaired over the
years using traditional methods
they have retained their authenticity
these buildings can tell us a lot about
the local construction methods
and the history of the region the
churches reflect the architectural
styles of the regions where they were
built
showcasing the hutsu halech boycott and
lemko traditions
for example the 15th century wooden
church of saint judy
in derhobic near your view is famous for
its unique frescoes
and iconostasis besides religious
motives
there are floral decorations and
compositions from everyday life they
reflect the way that the citizens of
medieval holy china
saw the world
[Music]
item number five the struve arc
the struve geodetic arc was recognized
as an object of outstanding
value to humanity it is a chain of
survey triangulations
that made it possible to establish the
size and shape of the planet
almost exactly it was established over a
40-year span in the 19th century
and named after an astronomer and
geodetist of german origin
the ark stretches for almost 3 000
kilometers to 10 countries
from the coast of the barren sea in
norway to the shores of the black sea in
ukraine
it consists of more than 200 main
station points
34 of the best preserved points are on
the unesco world heritage list
four of these are in ukraine three in
padilla and one in basarabia
[Music]
these measurements were used by
scientists until the end of the 20th
century
it became possible to fine-tune them
using research carried out by satellites
item number six quasi of ceramics the
tradition of quasi-painted ceramics
evolved in kosiv and other nearby
villages
ceramic pieces covered in white clay are
painted with three colors
green yellow and brown symbolizing
mountains
the sun and the earth respectively the
motifs on toys dishes
and tiles depict the hootsuit's history
life
folklore beliefs and traditions as well
as the floor and fauna of the region
you can admire cossi of ceramics in
multiple exhibition halls
of hudson's museums
the tradition of course of painted
ceramics is being kept alive
and developed by small scale producers
and private workshops
kosiv college has its own department of
artistic ceramics several of the museums
in hutsushina
have exhibition rooms dedicated to this
art
item number seven cave picharas lavra
and saint sophia's cathedral
in 1990 these became the first places in
ukraine
to be added to the unesco world heritage
list
the majestic gold dome monastery of cave
piccers
lavra is a distinctive feature of the
cave skyline
it was founded by yaroslav mudre
yaroslav the wise
during the golden age of kevin russ the
lava consists of two unique
underground complexes monastic buildings
churches
and bell towers surrounded by defensive
walls
for a long time the complex was among
the most important
christian cultural and pilgrimage
centers of the world
the lava still holds church services
there are working churches
a monastery the cave theological academy
and the residents of the metropolitan
the head of an ecclesiastical part of
the ukrainian orthodox church
the area also belongs to the national
cave pacific
historical and cultural reserve there
are several museums on the site
with collections that include ancient
manuscripts icons
works of embroidery and etchings
like the lavra saint sophia's cathedral
was erected in the 11th century
right after the christianization of
kevin ruse
it is one of the key monuments of
architecture and monumental art of the
period
influencing the design and decoration of
churches across eastern europe
until the 13th century it was the main
cathedral of the capital of the
christian
principality saint sophia's cathedral
and the adjacent monastery complex
combine features of the byzantine and
ukrainian baroque styles
their ancient interiors have been
preserved along with the largest
collection of mosaics and frescoes of
that period
today the territory belongs to the sofia
kevska
national reserve item number eight
the primeval beach and old growth
forests of the carpathians
ukraine is particularly rich in natural
heritage
the primeval beach forests of the
carpathians are on the unesco heritage
list
covering extensive areas of forest
across 20 european countries
in ukraine 15 sections of forest
belonging to biosphere reserves
and national nature parks were added to
the list
the primeval beach forests are an
example of untouched ecosystems
in the temperate zones providing a
valuable genetic pool
for the european beech tree forests like
these
used to cover 40 of the surface area of
europe
thanks to reserves such as these
researchers are better able to study the
evolution of
beech and other plants from this
particular geographical area
among the forest sites on the heritage
list these forests are home to
particularly unique
flora and fauna especially species that
have adapted to live in caves
item number nine the residents of
bukovena and dalmatia metropolitans
the official name of the site might not
ring any bells
but chennai national university is on
many people's
must-see list academic premises were set
up here
in the middle of the 20th century
however the architectural complex
was constructed in the times of the
austro-hungarian empire
as the center of the bucovena orthodox
metropolis
the residence consists of three
monumental buildings
the metropolitan's building the seminary
and the monastery
and an arboretum it represents a
remarkable synergy of classical
architectural styles
as well as the art of local ethnic
groups the complex was built using only
locally sourced building materials
this grandiose building project
contributed to the development
of production facilities in chernivtsi a
masonry conveyor
two brick factories and a ceramics
factory
the bricks were subject to a meticulous
quality control process
including a sound test visitors to this
unesco site can take a guided tour
available in various different languages
[Music]
item number 10 taurak kersunis and its
kora
over 2000 years ago in southwestern
crimea
on the site of the modern city of
sevastopol a fascinating city was
founded tauraq hirsunis even today
you can see the remains of this ancient
city-state or polis
as well as its agricultural suburbs or
hora
in 2013 it was unanimously voted
on to the unesco world heritage list
taurec jersenize
was a classic greek polis and an
important political and economic hub
in northern prichorno moria it was also
a cultural crossroads for
the greek roman and byzantine empires
at the time of the russian occupation of
crimea in 2014
the taurek hersonis museum and
archaeological site
housed over 200 000 exhibits discovered
during the excavations
these include the remains of the
defensive walls residential areas
and artisan workshops due to military
and commercial use
of the site under russian occupation the
world heritage site of tariq
hirsunis is threatened with destruction
[Music]
unesco is an organization that seeks to
promote peace and security
through international cooperation in the
fields of education
science and culture its programs focus
on areas that include
access to education international
scientific cooperation
the preservation of tangible and
intangible heritage
and the free flow of information as a
unesco member state
ukraine is bound to move consistently
towards
the goals set by the organization we
have a lot to develop
preserve and admire
[Music]
you